[Music]
and we are live from play NYC we have
the legend its annual podcast loads
given that we have the legend and Butch
Coe how you doing sir I'm good I'm so
happy this is finally happening
2019 play NYC let's start from the
beginning like as far as the beginning
of how this tape was a developer only
thing and then it kind of birthed into
this what was the initial vision from
the beginning sure so we had play
crafting started literally 10 years ago
as a meetup group in New York so that
the first ever thing was just 30 game
developers in the back of the bar in
like March of 2009 showing each other
like games on their laptops so for five
years it was just a meetup group and
then it was just growing and growing and
growing and so I came in in 2014 and
built an actual company in an
organization around and in service of
that community so it started as all
developers and really developers are
still like the core of what we're doing
and the core of everything but because
more and more developers were showing
off more and more games players and fans
and influencers and streamers and media
just like started getting more and more
excited about it
so what we did is we started running a
quarterly play test event and
playtesting is when game players get to
play a game before it's done so that
their feedback helps shape how the game
is that's awesome yeah how it's finished
kind of like when a beta is released
publicly the play tests are typically
like in person like the events that we
were
yeah so we were doing like four of those
a year they were seasonal but because
more and more people were going to them
at one point I was like this isn't a
play test this is an expo the next ball
like this why yeah selling their games
here too and so we still do with those
Expos we were doing four of them for a
year but the summer one we decided all
right New York needs its own all games
so the scale convention games only like
let's do it and let's take that summer
one and like blow it out I'm so glad you
said that because one of the things that
inspired me about Dan is you said
something key you said if you wanted to
get into games I saw this one of your
old player NYC's that it kind of sucked
that you had to go to San Francisco you
had to go to Boston and pass and to see
you bring that vision to New York City
our home most of the home with the Lords
here it's something that we really hold
near and dear and you keeping this alive
so as far as what do you think are the
detractors to take to keep it from
getting to where it needed to be some of
the obstacles you may have faced
initially too for what they are just
bringing a convention to New York City
because some of this is something we've
always wanted for a long time I think a
big thing is cost so I'm like very very
adamant that the convention needs to be
in Manhattan because it's central to
Jersey the region the airport's the like
New York itself the five boroughs love
all the borough's but Manhattan is right
in the middle and honestly like if you
want to be like super central and really
accessible like Manhattan
no sense it makes the misspoke sense
logistically and again from a venue
standpoint remember like terminal
terminal five then you did like cameras
through commerce on a ballroom and now
the pavilion gonna say how did that come
about so that came about because you
know the first and second year PlaNYC
wasn't really super known yet and so I
thought it was really important to find
like a very New York unique venue and
just like fill it with games in a way
that it had never been done before to
kind of like get the attention on it to
showcase the developers put it in a
place that just like the general public
players like just knew of and so that
was really like a big goal in the first
couple years this year it was like
alright we've done this two years
already we know it's a thing we know we
can grow it how can we find a space in
Manhattan that is just one giant floor
that we can like more proactively design
and experience for people around and so
yeah so so now with everything being on
one floor and everything being sort of
centralized yeah we're able to like map
out a path for like how we want people
to experience like we like the activity
of walking through play in YC to be a
game in and of itself it's a game of
games so it is like there's a lot of
design that goes into it the team spent
like 30 to 40 hours on
the floor and it shows yeah and at the
same time you know there already are so
many events that happen at convention
centers and and you know we want to grow
and grow and grow playing myci to the
point that we need to go somewhere like
that but in the meantime going to places
that are very have a very unique feel to
them you know this is one giant show
floor but there's all these pillars but
these like great lights that we can do
like rainbow colors all throughout
he's got the colors pop and he's got
everything that yeah one thing I want to
mention is also I feel like playin YC
it's a very intimate feel with a
developer and that you guys welcome
feedback I mean the developers welcome
feedback and I thought that is very
helpful in the whole construction
process is that something that you
encouraged the devs to do or how's the
whole mentality behind so absolutely and
I think that's where the difference was
playing in YC is that we are doing
events in New York and other cities all
year round with these developers and
many other developers like them a lot of
folks come in just for playing my C just
cuz it's so big but like we like our
team knows the stories of most of these
developers
and the ones that are new we encourage
them to like keep coming back and to
come to things that we're doing in their
city or close to them and so so yeah
they're really baked into the show
itself right from the start because like
on our end but we're going to be held
accountable because it's we're not just
doing one thing for a year like we're
seeing everybody all year round you know
so like being as transparent as we can
be having like feedback forms on our end
as which is also organizing perspective
and yeah the fact that there's a lot of
studios here and teams here that are
smaller making indie games mobile games
tabletop games there are like a great
bunch of like larger Studios here too
but the core of our community started
out as that meetup group and so you get
to you're not there with like a brand
ambassador that's showing the game right
on behalf of a developer most of the
booths here are being run by the
developers who are actively making their
games that that's the difference and I
think you just nailed it that's what I
felt initially again it's an intimate
feel you're getting hands-on with the
creators and that to me is an experience
that's worth the price of admission so
from me personally I've seen my guys
from decoy games are here we met them at
pax we did coverage on our packs for
iron law podcast it was absolutely
phenomenal to see their journey and to
see how that's going on and there's been
so many other games I pariah tee of
games is really impressive man and I
just want that thank you keep the vision
alive but New York City man this means
so much to us and where else do you
envision play craft and going in the
future well right now we're in New York
Boston and San Francisco and we've
started doing some events especially
through our partnership with bows and
other partners that have come in and
shot out the bull's eye off to show the
bull's eye of our big sponsor is
represent yeah yeah we've started to do
some events in San Diego Seattle
and some other places too and so I like
this idea of being a place for
developers from smaller teams and
smaller studios maybe they work on their
own to also like interact with like huge
companies like Bose the games in the
Bose a arcade were made by developers in
New York they're launching at this
convention Wow
they were all paid like they were paid
to make those games like it is it's
legitimate and they it's this really
powerful way where we can be community
first and also help support businesses
and help get games into stores and so I
want this to be a place where both
community and business and success all
can kind of gel together and just really
showcase the diversity of the games
themselves the people who make them that
beautiful play them right it's really a
mirror image of what is so great about
New York that's awesome you said that
and that vision ultimately I think can
pay off I think one of the other hurdles
I was gonna ask you about was just like
from a tax break perspective it's not
easy to come to New York from a
developer publisher standpoint you know
are we still making any progress in that
and to get even more sometimes of the
bigger bigger games to feel comfortable
to come out to New York say say hey it's
okay gonna have to break the budget just
yeah there's there certainly I think
that's one of the big factors here so
places like California Montreal
they have like tax incentives for
developers so that it encourages these
larger companies to set up offices so
the best part about playing YC and about
New York and about our community and
folks like us is that there is very much
that New York mentality where it's like
like don't tell me that I can't do it
here even without that kind of subject
we do have Avalanche Studios we do have
people who can fly you know
salut yeah dot says it's a mobile studio
but they are huge so it's it's a again a
reflection of that New York attitude and
so the folks that have it and that are
in it are kind of going against all odds
succeeding some failing and so we want
to be here to make sure that like
there's a consistent support network for
them again this is awesome and I mean
this is the Lord's first play NYC not
the last not the last definitely not the
last it's one of these things that again
New York City the mecca right it's only
right that we have our own conference
that we have our own convention and
we're gonna do our best to support this
thing man and to keep your vision alive
this has been a fantastic event we love
what we see then keep up the fantastic
work play and watching the build and
butch go
the legendary Dan which go iron law park
as his Lord cocky dough head absolute
pleasure once again and do it we'll see
you more of you and hopefully get you
and I'll be in the future and break down
your history even more so call awesome
thank you for being here final off
podcast Lords a game of net
[Music]